la période des fêtes de fin d'année
c'est aussi l'occasion de penser à ceux
qui ont moins de chance ceux pour qui
noël ne rime pas forcément avec joie et
cadeaux c'est le cas des orphelins du
dombass pour qui nicolas depuis
plusieurs années se mobilisent mobilise
la communauté française pour leur venir
en aide nicolas bonjour bonjour nicolas
ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi consiste votre démarche oui bien
sûr écoutez nous sommes certain nombre
de français ici
on réussit à
être
vraiment très imbriqué avec la vie
russe avec le business russe moi
personnellement ça fait 22 ans que je
suis là et on a décidé de faire quelque
chose parce que bon on était quand même
peu et n'est gêné par tous ces
événements et
en fait on a décidé tout de suite de se
rassembler de trouver des fonds et
de faire ce qu'on pouvait faire
c'est-à-dire
de
d'allumer une terre d'urgence voilà
concrètement nicolas avec son équipe est
accompagné du père noël sillonne la
région de donetsk pour rendre visite aux
familles en difficulté mais les cadeaux
ne sont pas fait au hasard les services
sociaux locaux ont en amont recenser les
besoins et les envies des enfants
l'action a été lancée pour les enfants
aux besoins particuliers
ce sont des enfants de militaires les
cadeaux ont été choisis individuellement
pour chacun nous avons travaillé pendant
très longtemps afin de comprendre ce
qu'il avait écrit dans leur lettre au
père noël et quelles étaient leurs rêves
ainsi grâce à la générosité de la
communauté française de russie et la
sollicitude de nicolas et son équipe ces
enfants du dombass ont eu droit à un
véritable noël et ont oublié l'espace de
quelques instants les difficultés de la
vie que tu veux